[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the number of ways these things can
present themselves is practically
infinite I mean I've seen I've had
really weird experiences with
information for instance you know these
splashes on buildings where the news
goes by I've had hallucinations where it
became a textual hallucination in other
words what I was seeing was an
illuminated page of print and then as I
looked at it every 50th the latter would
invert and then suddenly every twentieth
and then every tenth and then every
fifth and I literally watch a page of
text go from being readable to being
gibberish and then watch the meaning
come through again in a loop I mean I
think anything you can conceive of it
can do and many things you can't
conceive of it we're all individuals we
all have the gift of bringing our own
ideas but still you have to be able to
make general statements about it or you
would have to say that it's all and
everything one of the one of the the
same would be boring but well although
how would you know since you would never
have any trip but your own one of the
things that happens on psilocybin and on
ayahuasca that really puzzles me that I
just go back to again and again is you
can be having these volleys of
hallucination and then you can say to it
art deco and click and suddenly there
will be thousands of cigarette lighters
limousines candy dishes stuff rolling in
black space in front of you thousands of
these things perfectly exemplifying this
very narrowly defined aesthetic domain
Italian Baroque click altarpieces
Saints with their eyes rolled back
dripping gold the whole thing and so
they say boy that is really straight
we click through esthetic epochs like
points on a dial but then you can say to
it surprised me and Baroque not on pear
not dynastic Egypt not North American
Indian Maya or Fujiwara Japanese but
something never seen on this planet but
equally coherent as those other styles
and I always think you know my god if I
could just grab hold of this I would be
if Santa Loren or Clem or somebody like
that the mushroom has a personality and
like all personality is exclude some
things and includes others the the
mushroom personality is a radically
eccentric personality the mushroom talks
about transforming the planet it says
you know I come from a distant part of
the galaxy I have 500 million years of
galactic history and my data banks I
have seen 50 thousand worlds come into
existence and pass out of existence
I think shift the size of Australia's
departs for Andromeda I've seen this
I've seen that it's willing to show you
the newsreels of it that kind of oh and
it says your world is ending put your
furry paw into my hands and together we
will march out to the stars
it's this well so then you take a
compound or if or a shamanic
hallucinogen like ayahuasca chemically
this is very very similar to DMT
experientially it could hardly be more
different
ayahuasca does not show you images of
enormous machines in orbit around alien
planets and that sort of thing
ayahuasca first of all it doesn't speak
it shows if you become like the eye of a
camera flying through a world and what
it shows you it's much more
eminent it shows you water falling over
the land it shows you plants life
growing and dying it shows you the
movement of glaciers over the surface of
the land it shows you people burying
their dead it shows you archaic
civilizations it shows you women nursing
their children it shows you neat it
shows you the stuff of this world on
every level and and it moves you to
tears
I mean it's emotive it's not about our
cosmic destiny out there in the starry
blackness it's about coming to terms
with the earth and our past I mean I've
seen states of group mindedness that
were so specific that there was no
possibility that what was not happening
was no sit one-on-one real-time
telepathy
take me to your leader no I did have one
DMT trip way back like maybe the second
or third or fourth way back where it was
completely different it's the only one
I've ever had like that and it was
completely different and the way I you
put it to myself was the big people were
home and it was an entirely different
feeling and many people actually I've
never quite had this myself but many
people report DMT trips where they broke
in on an entity who is not pleased at
all and demands to know how the hell you
got there and you know who are you and
you know then various sorts of dialogs
go on and one person described being
then just hurled through all of time
like exploded back from this thing and
going through all the recapitulation of
on taja me and it's weird stuff DMT
trips I mean mine are always as I
described but some people report and
these may be synergies with
antidepressants or something like that
but apparently very stable and strange
world
I mean worlds with alien people's and
animals and cities and you know very
science fictiony stuff that's why this
Bell's Theorem I don't think we use that
word that this nonlocality that we
talked about may have something to do
with the phenomenon of the imagination
like it's occurred to me over the years
that what we call imagination might
simply be hyper dimensional perception
and you're actually seeing worlds and
places that truly exist somewhere
scattered through
the galaxy's like grains of sand but no
place you will ever contact or visit in
the flesh but that the batter is somehow
present there seems to be some kind of
tuning thing that needs to go on I you
know possibly with technology I had a
really weird experience years ago I took
LSD one evening with a bunch of people
and it was fairly casual and social and
smoked a bunch of weed this went on for
a couple of hours and it didn't really
ever seem to come on it just seemed to
be very light and then I climbed on my
motorcycle and went home and decided I
would go to bed and I decided that I
would smoke that one last joint before
going to bed and I had one of those
standeth electrical resistance heaters
that you get in at the Salvation Army
you know if you're a Porsche student and
I said so I turned it on as I started to
smoke this joint and it was badly wired
and it made this sound like
[Music]
and as I began to listen to the sound I
like went to lizard land and I entered
into this completely coherent thing
which lasted for hours about this world
inhabited by these intelligent reptilian
beings and we went through their art
their history their theories of jewelry
making their philosophy their polity
their science their religion their
fashion there and it was like very
specific reptilian world
well then later I tried again and I took
LSD with my arm around my heaters been
preaching it in the streets and I could
never really find my way you know which
is a typical phenomenon of higher higher
dimensional phase space wealth taught me
you know doing the reverse of what you
did doesn't steer you back to where you
started
you have to find your way forward
through the matrix
[Music]
kath and I were in the Amazon in 76
taking ayahuasca we got in with a
certain group of people in Peru that
took it every week and you know cultures
have different ways of handling hassle
and in some cultures its confrontational
in other cultures not the way these
Peruvian country folk operated was if
somebody was screwing up
nobody would ever say so they would just
talked about these people behind their
back until the Marco genetic field of
gossip was so strong that you would
basically awaken to the problem so there
was a complex social situation going on
in this ayahuasca circle which was there
was a master shaman who we were
apprenticed to who was beloved by his
neighborhood but he had a nephew a
sobrino who was a jerk I mean this guy
was as Don Fidel said ambitious he dealt
a little lead he did a little pimping he
was just sort of an edger Runner type of
guy and every Saturday night we would
all get together and take ayahuasca
about 30 of us older shamans are guy
people from the neighborhood and this
Sabrina Don Jose so I don't know what
the real history of it was because I
have just arrived on the scene but these
old guys would sing these echoes these
magical songs on ayahuasca that appear
as colored tapestries in front of your
eyes and you know they were they had
soul they were into it they were and
this guy would sing against them I mean
it's the ruh this thing you can possibly
imagine
I mean imagine if if
you know Lou Reed we're trying to give
her performance than the guy in the
third row just launched into old-man the
river and you know I mean in this town
I'm sure large guys would appear and say
sir
in Peru it didn't work like that
they just kept singing he kept singing
and it was clear that this is how it was
gonna be handled that we had just
divided into two separate entities here
well my wife was sitting next to me and
he was sitting across the room from us
the sobrino and I had been watching him
for a long time and I was loaded to the
gills and I could see he would get up on
his haunches and he he looked like a
monkey he he his face it was uncanny I
mean he looked like a monkey and he also
looked kind of like a jackal a dog with
long teeth kept going through these
changes and and Kathleen Dover to me and
said something like the skies of an
[ __ ] woman I just said you know let
it slide what do we know think of it as
anthropology he she wasn't having it so
after a while he kept doing this and at
one point and everybody in the room
every person in the room was bummed out
and they were looking at their laughs
all eye contact was broken it's actually
when I was a kid I invented a word the
word is far dow and it means the
embarrassment you feel when someone else
[ __ ] up you know and you happen to just
be there but somehow the aura that is so
strong the entire room is just a wash
and farted out and the old guys are
singing and the guy is singing so then
at the end of a particularly intense
clash of these two styles my wife just
looked across the room at this guy and
like put a climbing on him and I saw
these red air
leave her eyes and like like dotted
lines and they move fairly slowly you
know slowly than you could throw a ball
or something will win this line of red
arrows got to this guy he was knocked
off his feet he fell backwards with his
legs in the air and there was a big
noise and all the singing stopped and
everybody in the room looked up and
these three old shaman who were sitting
behind Don Fidel who I to that point had
not heard speak any language but Quechua
one turn to the other and he says in
Spanish oh the gringa
[Laughter]
the girlfriend in the other dimension
the mushroom once I said to it to her I
almost said once I said to her I said
what should I call you and she said call
me Dorothy
[Laughter]
so I invoke it and it comes it comes and
then and then we're off and sometimes
it's easy and loving and sometimes it's
different I remember one very epic trip
I had where I had tossed out a big
compost pile from growing mushrooms
years ago in another country it actually
was a past life I'm now recalling but
anyway I tossed out this stuff and this
thing grew this humongous mushroom and I
had taken mushrooms the previous
Saturday I had taken a full dose which
is five dried grams so I thought I want
to take mushrooms again this Saturday
but I I think I may have picked up a
tolerance so I'll just take nine grams
instead and this is where the learning
takes place the mistakes treasure your
mistakes so the thing it's like I'm
sitting there and suddenly I realize oh
my god it's coming
at me it's a hundred miles wide it's ten
miles high and it is rolling toward me
it looks and and I barely had time to
lay down that's how fast it and a boy
said yep
prepare the storm is about to hit the
beach and and I laid down and it was
just it was like a tornado hitting and
at one point I opened my eyes and the
there was this woman in a full bondage
Yetta
with you know piercings and rubber
panties and the whole thing and she and
I was lying there between her legs she
was standing upright and and she put her
face right down back to mine and she
said is it strong enough for you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
to which I replied yes and she said and
then she said they say it helps to close
your eyes cowboy and I later in thinking
about that trip I realized the reason
the goddess the reason the mushroom
addressed me as cowboy is because that's
most people mushrooms have met have been
cowboys and cowgirls cuz they're the
people who follow the cows and most
people have encountered this thing in
the pasture you know Maria Sabina the
mushroom shamaness of Oaxaca claimed not
to have been initiated she claimed that
as a child left to watch the sheep and
the cows she had been hungry and had
gotten into eating mushrooms once I was
in India and I was cornered this guy I
was loaded actually on mescaline and
this guy swam aboard my my houseboat and
normally I just would run these guys off
because they were thieves and beggars
but I was so
did though I couldn't do anything but
sit there and this guy came up to me and
sat down across from me and looked at me
and after a few minutes he said face his
index of mind and I said Ranji I can't
be interrogating now but it was this
thing he could see faces index of mine
my mind was swirling visibly there at
times appeared to work miracles at one
point I I was trying to test him and his
abilities and I recall that there was a
box that my grandfather had given me
that you opened with a little silver key
that had been lost for years and years
and he I said well if you can do
anything
why don't you produce the key that to
that box which neither of us had seen
even the box for a dozen years by this
time he was naked and locked in a room
at the mission and and he went in he
would make these bizarre gestures these
strange
arkad I don't know what was going on and
he he went into a period of
concentration gave a wild squawk and
slammed into my hand and gave me the key
Jeff gave me the key who was naked he
had been locked in this room for 14 days
at that time and I was like I didn't
know what was going on but what was
happening to me was I was like utterly
unconcerned for his mental health or any
practical concern which was causing a
lot of problems for the other people on
the expedition in classical psychology
this is called a date a fall a adieu a
delusion
- it's a simultaneous schizophrenic
episode it usually involves a mother and
a daughter I've never heard of a brother
brother while a I do but it was
accompanied by all these exterior
manifestations freak rainbows and in my
case an encounter with the UFO and this
UFO encounters had a very curious
quality to it not that they don't always
vote but this was even more curious than
the pedestrian UFO encounter what
happened was it was on the fort it was
on the 13th day of the reversal and that
I had had this intimation there was
something going on about the Southwest I
wasn't clear quite what it was and the
two women on the expedition were that
afternoon washing our clothes down by
the choro by the lake and I looked
across the lake and I saw in the sky not
a rainbow but just a spot in the sky
that was a spectra Grammatik diffraction
you know a little patch of rainbow and I
asked the women if they saw it and they
said they didn't and then it intensified
and by this time I was plenty in the
doghouse as well I mean this put a great
deal of strain on our small party as you
can imagine and this Spectre dramatic
you're a dual intensified and then I
said to them now do you see it and they
looked and they said oh yeah mmm it's no
big deal not much but I knew I knew
and knowing means the voice was speaking
to me all kinds of weird things went on
I mean I discovered that I that the
closer I was to water the easier it was
for me to rhyme
at which I'd never and then years later
I encountered the Celtic saying poetry
is made at the edge of running water and
and the thing would give me these
aphorisms like one time it said the
clones load is a stoned mode and you
know and I was not sleeping I was now 11
days without sleep so that night I
decided to sit by the choro and just
because I stayed up all night and I
would walk in the fields and the thing
would draw the would connect up the
constellations for me and show me where
they were in the sky there was also
embedded in all this thing the
intimation of this thing called the
teacher which was a giant insect like
thing that was always like right over
here and there was the sense of
something watching us from the sky
something moving us very very gently but
persistently toward this very weird
breakthrough
[Music]
but I hear you asking is what about the
dark side of psychedelics and I think
that's certainly worth talking about it
isn't a joyride necessarily one thing
that is quite wonderful about
psychedelics is that and I'll just speak
of the mushroom in this case is that
it's wonderfully kind to beginners but
if you are an acolyte of the priesthood
sooner or later it will scare the socks
off you and in many ways it can do this
in fact that's what's so scary about it
is it knows the way to scare you just
like it knows everything else about you
and so so in my talk I stress the
facility with which one can access these
places and I sort of teased yoga it is
easy to access these places the question
is then but is it easy to control and
manipulate and understand these places
and this is where it can turn you every
way but loose this is where you want to
have your mantras polished and your
Yantra is ready because in that domain
it all works
all that malarkey that doesn't ever work
anywhere else in that domain it works
and and so I think one should have
techniques you know the ring pass not or
mantras something that you have faith in
power objects ultimately the best advice
I've ever come on and you know it's
pretty sickening advice but the goal is
to survive these things is Frank
Herbert's advice in doom about fear and
he says fear comes like a wind it comes
and the way you need it is you need it
and you wait and it blows and it blows
and it blows itself out and then you're
alone again and that's what you have to
do and then in terms of practical
instruction there are way ways to
navigate through hard spots birth
control
singing singing is wonderful we tend to
suffer silently and if you get into a
pressurised place on a psychedelic I
don't think it's a good idea to go to
squeeze down and meet it like that I
think it's much better to sing to you
know circulate huge volumes of oxygen
through your body and just send your
whole metabolism spiralling off in some
other direction shamanism was defined by
the foremost commentator on it mursili
odd as the archaic techniques of ecstasy
notice its techniques and this is really
important this is not a religion or an
ontology or a set of beliefs like
Buddhism Hinduism Catholicism you name
it it's a set of techniques and the
techniques deliver the experience and
then out of the experience one creates
whatever models of the universe seem
appropriate that this is what science
was before science this is what religion
was before religion and it's deep it's
the deepest thing there is our society
living in ignorance of this is infantile
and destructive and narcissistic and
materialistic and the whole gamut
because we can't touch the gold in life
you know it's hard for us it's very
invasive it's far from us authenticity
is fleeting and we require
psychotherapists
some self-affirmation all the stuff to
hang on to it how I got into this was
the gentleman who asked the question is
by being in the Amazon by having
searched India to see so you know what
can you show me and they couldn't show
me anything they wanted me to sweep the
ashram for 12 years and then something
wonderful was going to happen and I am
bet then when I got to South America I
reckon you shining in the sky said let's
sharpen our machetes we'll go out here
and get some of this snake line and come
back and I'll show you and by 10 o'clock
that night you know I was sobbing in the
guy's arms he showed me I was a condor
I'd sweep his courtyard for 12 years
without asking
[Music]
I my daughter who I haven't seen for a
while is coming today and it caused me
to think of an incident that happened to
she and I years ago here at Esalen and
it's a story which makes no sense
whatsoever but it really truly happened
as far as I can tell but it has all the
qualities that bedeviled this kind of
thing and what it was was I was as I am
now scholar in residence it must have
been some 10 years or so eight years or
so ago so Cleo would have been like nine
and I would have been 40 so we were both
younger and more naive and we it was
dinner time at the lodge and it was this
time of year and this time of weather
and the fog had been coming all day in
and out in the garden and it was and we
genuflect hear God love him to carlos
castaneda it was that very strange time
of day which only lasts a few minutes
between daytime and nighttime the crack
between the world I believe it's
interesting in in South America and also
in Hawaii at precisely that moment every
day there are certain species of
Lepidoptera that rearrange themselves in
other words that come out from wherever
they've been hiding for 24 hours fly
around furiously for five minutes and
then disappear again for 24 hours but
anyway it was precisely that time of day
and the fog was coming in and out of the
garden and we were not in a mood for
anything peculiar we were intent on
dinner and we were walking the path
through the garden and
suddenly as this fog moved and cleared
coming down one of the rows was a bunny
a small rabbit except that it it had
very small short horns now some of you
may know the creature called the
Jackalope the Jackalopes is the large
Jackrabbit with a pair of antelope horns
and it is a creature known only to exist
above certain low-class bars scattered
across California and Oregon it's up on
the wall
the Jackalope it's something you kid
tourists with as far as I could see this
was a baby jackal Oh about this high and
it it crossed the trail no more than
five feet in front of us we both saw it
and our attitude was not amazement or an
awareness that we were entering into a
paranormal dimension both of us I think
our reaction was come and then
immediately behind it was a man a very
thin not particularly healthy looking
man with a shaved head wearing something
like a grey running suit and he was
running crouched he was with his arm
hands out like this he was trying to
catch the the jaca bunny and when he saw
us he appeared very confused and stood
up and turned and walked the other way
and I just took her by the elbow and I
said
let's get out of here and then we went
to dinner and we've talked about it
immediately after and since and as far
as anybody can reasonably undi cently
tell this is the straight story on what
happened well it doesn't make any sense
first of all the earth doesn't move from
its pinions but what does it say it says
that attention falling into a certain
place of non attention is set up for
something like this to happen and I
don't I can't explain it I don't think
it's explainable
it's sort of like you know when you
study quantum physics and they tell you
that a black hole mostly puts out
electrons but the theory allows that it
could be jekt Miatas and grand pianos
except that it would be very rare for it
to eject a grand piano but the theory
does not preclude the injection of grand
pianos so it's something like that or
it's a group hallucination or it's a B
which meant or or or and it begins to
proliferate I was thinking about it last
night or this morning because I was in
that place where I saw it happen I was
thinking maybe maybe Esalen lasts a
really long time like maybe it's sort of
like the Piazza San Marco in Venice or
the Central Arian Stonehenge
maybe we're actually starting something
here that will last so long that for the
next 5,000 years people will relate to
the Esalen garden and that somehow it's
a nexus for others
on strange missions now the other thing
about that story that I like or that
relieved me as I guess the way to put it
is notice that it's absurd and by being
absurd its self cancelling suppose
instead of a Jackalope which is an
absurd creature to begin with suppose it
had been a gray of the wrap-around I
type that are apparently trading high
technology to the government for human
fetal tissue those people then you would
have had a real dilemma on your hands
because Gray's are objects of cultural
fascination in other words if you see a
gray you just become part of a
statistical body of people who've seen
one and so it's like more problematic
it's not that it's a non reality it's
that it's a sort of a non reality this
is I think part of the clue to alien to
understanding alien abductions and the
way we generate information if I tell
you that I was up late last night and
couldn't sleep and walked along the
cliffs over Esalen and that I
encountered a shining disc and that I
then had and my navel lint was removed
by a team of extraterrestrial
cosmetologist this is evidence for an
already existing body of data if you say
well you should call MUFON they'd be
very interested in this or you should
call somebody else if I tell you I was
Restless last night and walked the
cliffs of Esalen and that I encountered
Bugs Bunny in the company of Patrick
Swayze people would just say you're nuts
you know it's not sanctioned it's not
allowed and nobody gives a hoot or takes
it seriously for a moment because it
serves no one's agenda it's just insane
data and should be immediately tossed
out this shows us you know that the
objects of in the unconscious are given
different weights and you can tell a
crazy story and join a self-help group
but if your story is too crazy they
won't have a group for you they'll have
a cell for you so it's worth bearing in
mind let's be generous here someone had
prepared a bunny with horns to surprise
someone else with whom they'd had a
lifelong running joke about Jackalopes
and they had arrived at Esalen for the
surprise birthday party of this person
and realized that the bunny was frantic
because it hadn't eaten on the long trip
so they took the jacket bunny in its
cage down to the garden to steal some
lettuce for it and in the fog and in the
effort not to be seen the bunny escaped
with its horns in place and this person
who probably didn't have a gate pass
anyway could see the whole situation
getting out of hand I was frantically
trying to capture the Horned bunny and
get it back in it's see people saying
gee what a party pooper this guy - well
yeah but we're trying to save the laws
of physics and reason here for crying
out loud
but I have to tell you that doesn't feel
right to what it is it it felt to me
like I don't know we all live in private
Idaho's and somehow I was in somebody
else's private Idaho for a moment
against my will but I think we should
always prefer the simplest explanation
sometimes the simple explanation like in
a case like that is maddeningly complex
in itself but if you don't believe
that's what's happened well then what do
you believe do you believe that
mythological animals are potential
infestation problem in the Esalen
gardens or just where do you draw the
line
I had an experience earlier this summer
which I probably shouldn't tell but I
will that is an example of how it gets
weird we had a friend of mine moved to
London and left me his library for
unspecified amounts of time to keep a
very bizarre library mostly platonic
stuff a lot of magic a lot of that sort
of thing and so we built a book loft for
it and our house is wedge-shaped and so
this book cloth is way up at the top of
the house and I was alone in the house
and I took seven dried grams and I was
sitting there and it was just beginning
to come on I was in the show what you
know thing phase and it was beginning to
show what it knew and there was this
disrupted area of space in front of me
where it was like rotating and I was
looking into it and talking it up and I
was actually speaking at first I was
just speaking in my mind then I would
began speaking aloud and I was saying
you are beautiful thing you are
beautiful
and suddenly there things changed and it
became very cold and meaning the
temperature fell suddenly and the dog
next door who never howls how old and
the cat which was down below me and I
was up in this loft looking down at our
bed the cat was on the bed the cat
flared out and made this really weird
noise and I just you know I stopped what
I was doing and projected my mind into
this situation and at that moment I
heard this sound which was like and then
something settled on to the roof
sufficient to make the six by fourteen
inch beam
creak in you swing and I was floored and
I just I just sat for a minute and I was
not frightened in fact my emotion was
hard to get back to but I wasn't
frightened but just at that moment these
this thing was really coming on and
really visually peculiar and it seemed
like the two things were independent the
trip was getting stronger and stronger
but a 10-ton something had landed on a
roof beam of my house so I just sat with
it for about 30 seconds and then this
thought or voice came and it was this
thing has come because of something I'm
doing and that means that I can get rid
of it so I just turned like this up
toward the roof and projected this
thought very strongly which was begone I
am in conversation with an elder and
this thing went and there was a long
pause ten seconds or so and then
whatever it was it lifted off the roof
and went away and what was weird about
this was I had never I had never ever
used in my own mind this phrase an elder
to describe the mushroom it was like
just came out of me
and the whole episode seemed real weird
to me and I just let it ride but that's
an instance where you know there is this
let's call it synchronicity so that we
don't have to believe that a pterodactyl
does my drug there is this synchronicity
for some reason their chose to be a
fluttering sound and the bean chose to
creak now doubtless this has to do with
temperature and the cooling of day to
night
but you know it was a thing to go
through
[Music]
there is something
[Music]
loose on this planet is that what I want
to say or behind reality or something I
we could call it the unconscious but
that might make you feel more
comfortable with it than you should but
what this power can do is it can
manipulate your mind and what it has
access to is the complete contents of
your experience it has more access than
you do you the ego are a fragile and
forgetful creature this thing every
movie you've ever seen every television
show you've ever watched every headline
you've ever glanced at ever every face
you've ever noticed in a crowd it has it
all and when it sits across the board
from you and the pieces are displayed it
it absolutely surrounds and encloses
your mental universe and can manipulate
you any way it wants to because it knows
you far better than you know yourself
as an example of this because it's very
hard to catch this thing in action it's
it's mercury sly but not it's not
perfect it's not God like it's just
99.8% able to do this trick without ever
being nailed to the wall for it here's
an example of the 0.02% where it failed
and you if this seems to make no sense
to you you should read my book true
hallucinations in which the story I'm
about to tell is embedded but my brother
too
short-handed catastrophic Lee went
pretty bananas in the course of this
expedition to the Amazon and at one
point he announced that he was going to
deliver a teaching that would I think
this was the one which cured all disease
you you only had to do this practice and
all physical disease would instantly be
cured and he said and so here's the
practice he said pictured the number-8
turn it on its side slide the two
circles together shrink it to a point
close your eyes and utter the mantra
please okay sounds like it has a 30 40
chance at least knocking back hayfever
right so so this was at a point in this
experience in the Amazon where he had
been raving for days and days and just
everybody was exhausted and at the wits
and and but it was like a bolt of
lightning to me because I remembered
that three months before I had been in
Canada having come from Japan and was
getting ready for this Amazon expedition
and one of the things that I thought I
should take care of since I'd been in
Asia for a couple of years was I needed
a dental check-up so I made an
appointment with this Canadian doc
dentist and went for this dental
cleaning and arrived to find a waiting
room full of people and settled down to
a tall stack of tattered and incredibly
tacky magazines among which was the
Journal of the Canadian education
society something like the
parent-teacher magazine but for Canada
and there was an article in there said
this was 1971 shows you how things never
change there was an article about how
computers will soon revolutionize
elementary school teaching and so you
know in desperation I turn to this
article and here's this article you can
imagine what it was saying but there was
this little sidebar next to the article
and it said the schools of the future
will be nothing like we have known
children will learn in completely
different ways and then it said imagine
little Susie sitting down in front of a
computer screen visualizing the number-8
turning it on its Sun sliding the two
circles over each other and shrinking it
to a point in order to command an
arithmetic operation or something like
that and it was like nailed nailed we
know where this stuff is coming from
it's coming from our own minds you know
hee hee if we want to blame my brother
for this had apparently a complete
readout of all this detritus flowing
around in my mind and could pick it up
and use it at will to befuddle and
confuse me and lead me deeper in when I
was schizophrenic if this is what we're
talking about my feeling about it was
and maybe this is if not true a delusion
worth playing with is I thought aha what
we call mental illness what we call
schizophrenia and what we look into the
body or the mind or the personal history
or the dream state to try and understand
and possibly cure
it's not like that at all it isn't your
if you're the person who's nuts
it isn't your problem it's something
that's happened to you not more
fundamentally than catching the flu it's
like you just happened to step in some
cosmic doo-doo and now it's on the
bottom of your shoe and everybody's
pointing at you and backing up but it
isn't your fault it was just happen to
be in your path it's a kind of it's a
horrible piece of luck unless you can
turn it to your own to your own
advantage and what that means I think is
obviously integrating it well then how
do you integrate these things I think
it's has to do again a lot with where
you start from just speaking from my own
personal experience what saved me was my
cynicism that I didn't believe in
anything never had had always thought
believing in things was a bad idea
so then when this whole cosmos of
beliefs was handed to me on a platter I
just simply said maybe you know I'll act
it out but I won't I won't believe it
and I think that had I been a good
Mormon a good Catholic a good Buddhist a
good something else then I would have
been lost because I would have traded
whatever it was I believed for the new
set of beliefs as it was I just said you
know what's this beliefs I don't do that
but I played with it and somehow the
playing with it was able to deep
attention it I had a conversation with
someone very recently who
by ordinary standards I think would have
to be considered nutty as a fruitcake
and you know they could hardly speak of
their condition without being swept by
an emotion that was so intense that it
reduced them to tears you know and I
said you know if you're gonna be this
nuts you should enjoy it more you know
it's - and they said you know I am
enjoying it and I said well I'm not
enjoying it because you're just
projecting such an emotional intensity
that it makes me very nervous and I
think I'm generally I speak then for the
same general masses about that what
makes it hard for the person is going
through this is that it's so hard for
other people
I mean it's freaky to be around somebody
who's crazy
[Music]
Denis had had this notion of what he
called the good [ __ ] this developed in
the days after the ideas of micro car
Malaysian and he claimed it was like a
family seems like a joke it wasn't clear
exactly what it was but it was this idea
that there was this hatch somewhere that
had been rolled into cow dung and cut
with cow dung and then infected with
psilocybin mycelium so that the mycelium
had completely replaced the cow [ __ ] in
this ball of hash for this hypothesized
kilos of hash somewhere in the world and
so there was this cybernated at one
point he envisioned us actually forming
a rock-and-roll band which would play
instruments that would condense this
stuff out of the air over large
audiences and you know we would go on
and at the end of the tour history would
be the whole thing would be in a
shambles because the Uncle John's band
really did come out of the woodland that
at one point he predicted one night
after he had been moved to the river and
was sort of in semi incarceration
[Music]
and so I left with my girlfriend of the
time and a man even in the st. Monica's
so for kids
an acute whirring rate and we made our
way like a quarter mile half a mile back
into the junk into this other place
where we were staying where the original
experiment had been done and so then we
get to the hut and it's pouring rain and
I had scored this kilo of Santa Marta
gold for the expedition and we have
smoked nothing like this for Colombia
relatively ragweed for weeks so my god
it out to roll the male's joint and and
I was fumbling with it and I got this
thing lit and this little this little
crumb flew burning they fell on the
floor and I lifted it out and
[Music]
the transubstantiation had occurred it
was you know like mazar-e-sharif
triple a Red Lion Ashish of some sort
and I know
Ashish I and here we were in the center
of the Amazon in this Hut in this
pouring rain and I could tell that it
was the good it was the good [ __ ] he did
it actually yes and I showed the woman
who was with me easily she didn't say it
wasn't
and I I stayed up late that night
smoking this incredible hash and waiting
for the rain to stop so that a first
grey light of dawn I could go down to
the river and confound my critics with
you know the stone sent the alchemical
quintessence but can Chris since the
excreta the good [ __ ] was
[Music]
and sat down by the hamlet cook was
sleeping formal I must for tsipras and
certain elbowed her awake
there were other instances where this
was the principle and work it what it
didn't work
everything has returned
like it was the Cinderella screw-up you
know it was just that I was a char girl
who washed rocks and there was no prints
and there was no culture there was no
and plus I was once again humiliated in
the presence of my critics who had
further reason to think that check in to
the local mental health care delivery
system
these things happen
you